Je devais te demander vérité ou défi
es-tu au courant qu'Olivia est amoureuse
de ton copain elle est à moi on arrête
Pénélope merde
Miguel Olivia commençons cette fête
type grenat vérité quelles sont tes
intentions avec notre suite Olivia j'avais
besoin de trouver quelqu'un avec des amis  que
je pourrais tromper en venant ici
Je pourrais dire qu'Olivia était une cible facile Je
vous ai tous amené ici parce que je suis d'accord
avec la mort d'étrangers si cela signifie que je peux
vivre ce que diable le jeu est réel d'
accord où que vous alliez quoi que vous fassiez
ça va te trouver d'accord ouais quelque chose de
vraiment bizarre se passe
depuis le Mexique oh allez
sérieux je vois des choses la
vérité là-bas mon cher je sais que ça semble fou
juste quelque chose que cette belle jeune femme ici
m'a défié de te montrer mon entreprise  Carter a
dit dis la vérité ou tu meurs fais le
défi ou tu meurs a refusé de jouer tu
ne baises pas cet homme tu meurs
Attends, je suis désolé, touche-moi ag  ain et je vais
casser cette main vérité ce n'est pas comme ça que
ça marche seul le jeu décide chérie casse
la main d'Olivia tu dois le faire avoir l'air aussi
énervé que je le suis en ce moment il n'y a
aucun moyen que je te casse la main tu
ne le fais pas  ayez vraiment le choix
Dieu faites-le ce jeu est trop intelligent la
moitié des personnes sur cette photo sont maintenant
mortes vous devez trouver le départ à gauche de
tout cela
comment pouvons-nous sortir de ce jeu vivant
vous ne pouvez pas ça ne se termine que par tous  les
joueurs sont morts bébé revient ensuite ose
moi te choisir cherche l'un de vous pour
tuer action ou vérité